this movie comes at a time in our and
our history in our culture where I guess
you know we're divided the message of
being a warrior of light is very
important so how do you become a warrior
of light it's a really interesting time
like with people being so incredibly at
different sides of political opinions of
ideology and I think this is a great
message in this film about you know
what's inside of you you know the truth
and you know what's truly good and you
know that in an all children have that
and and all people have that and it's
sort of sourcing that inside yourself
your father's trapped by energy it's too
strong for our light and the only one
who can stop it is you BRE was there a
point in your life or even a person in
your life that served as a guardian
angel for you helping you along your
journey to kind of find yourself mmm so
yes you said but I was um I remember
being in the newsroom in Baltimore and I
had a news director that would yell in
the newsroom every night when we're just
supposed to have the coffee turning
[Music]
every single day I would be trembling at
my desk because I wasn't a strong writer
and I just like oh god I'm a if I don't
get a good fight and so I didn't get
fired what they did was they demoted me
and put me on the talk show and that's
when my life took off yeah because I
wasn't supposed to be in news what was
the experience like for the three of you
getting to share scenes together and
share all this time together in a
beautiful place like New Zealand it was
fine
we had some fine I I think I was the
master of fun I ran for office and
elected myself yes to be the administer
of fun yeah and we had a really good
time what was your favorite phrase I'm
gonna squeeze the juice out of this
orange
at the time of our like we were on
helicopters and having margaritas yeah
she had a schedule it was so much to do
in one day I go I'm tired job I cannot
do the boat thing do the mountain hiking
then go to the place you'd be yoga to do
the thing and then do the tequila and
then dinner a big dinner but you know
you did a lot of it I did a lot of it no
I have a little more juice left in my
room so the costumes are extravagant
elaborate they're they're beautiful if I
was wearing one of them I'd be worried
every single day I would trip and fall
and rip them and them and be like did
you ever get that color in it at work of
art you ever have a you it like tumbled
in the new zealandtown that with flower
helpers sure but in real life there I
know flowers they're helping oh no it
wouldn't almost him oh I spilled coffee
on that white costume oh boy it was so
bad y'all are you were in the backyard
to remember the backyard we ate peeps
are you tumbled in the